you don't get a break in this film you
haven't had a break for six films now
it's like as soon as Alice thinks she
can breathe something else is coming at
her right I'm giving Alice the night off
nothing's gonna happen right nothing bad
what would Alice studious she would she
would be really depressed I know what to
do with herself I mean she's a
gunslinger
you know gunslingers need something to
shoot if I was to give your character
the night off what is your character
gonna do okay into a jacuzzi relax eat
have lots of alcohol to be able to sleep
that night and then the next morning use
the bottle the empty bottles for as
weapons I think that she put herself and
honestly a cell where no one could get
into it so that she could just sit and
breathe for a moment
I suppose paved the way for females sure
to lead and lead as an ensemble what
does that meant to you
um I think it's incredible you know when
I first signed on ten years ago I loved
the role of Claire Redfield but I also
love the idea that I was joining a
female led franchise and they've never
pit us against each other you never see
us fighting you see us supporting each
other and pushing each other up and this
movie to me yeah there's the zombies and
the killing and all that and people love
that stuff that's the movie to then but
an underlying theme is that you know
boys can do a good but come on girls can
do it too one of the things I think is
cool is the men are outnumbered in terms
of badassery yes so what happens with
that dynamic when you get on set are you
like everyday meal and Ally where we're
making everything look really simple and
every time that I was talking with him
about this earlier if we ever found like
we've had a tough day because we don't
we're running around for 14 hours and
jumping O'Lakes meal and I Lear sitting
I haven't liked laughing they're just
that babies pretty much in between takes
we're like heaven like William and I got
a blister don't tell anybody what was
the last scene you shot it was like 2:30
in the morning and we're doing all of
all of the stuff that we didn't get
pretty much for the rest of production
we're like now cramming it all in like
all those little shots of like
shoot here shoot there like and just
random stuff and you know there's a
whole bar laid out for the wrap party
and so they said cut and everybody was
like alright and they and they left to
go drink when I was kind of left
standing by myself and no one said
that's a wrap for me oh yeah yeah they
always everybody got applause and I
didn't now of course everyone makes
jokes and they start clapping for me I'm
like no I don't need applause now but
thank you I appreciate it
[Music]
[Music]
you